with the big summit president obama had
this week he invited a lot of muslim
groups to the white house to say
terrorism has nothing to do with islam
to which they said then why are we here
why didn't you invite a bunch of
presbyterians so
uh there's also this article this week
in the atlantic they got a lot of play
it's called what
isis really wants by a guy named graham
wood
and i want to show the quotes a few
quotes from obama that a few quotes are
missed because they're diametrically
opposed and then you tell me who's right
obama some of the things he said were no
religion is responsible for terrorism
people are responsible for violence and
terrorism that sounds a lot like the nra
slogan by the way
yeah okay it's don't kill yeah yeah okay
people
he also said the notion that the west is
at war with islam is an ugly lie
even though he's dropping bombs at them
all the time uh
now here's from the atlantic this is
from graham wood he said the reality
is that the islamic state is islamic yes
it is attracted psychopaths but the
religion
preached by its most ardent followers
derives from coherent
and even learned interpretations of
islam
uh so who's right about this you know i
think
neither are right and neither are really
hitting the nail on the head
i wasn't expecting that rob well look at
that
you're triangulating no i'm not
triangulating i'm trying to get at a
truthfulness here
which is if you look at the most violent
uh uh
islamic groups whether it's isis or
al-qaeda
these are essentially sunni based
the the muslim world was divided 1400
years ago between
sunni and the sunnis are exerting their
uh will and their control right now and
they would not be
where they are now especially in syria
and iraq had we not removed saddam
hussein
which kept that area together with him
he looks better
although well no i'm not no he does i'm
not saying and gaddafi too
well i'm not saying saddam hussein is a
good guy he wasn't a good guy but the
world it doesn't
you know it's not about what's the best
thing it's i mean it is about what's the
best there are sometimes no good answers
it's just the best ones
i agree and we had them in a box and we
had them contained right and now you
have
the sunnis who were basically uh you
know pushed aside
are now asserting themselves and so
basically it's it's a
it is a religious war but it's a
religious sectarian war
and to paint it all as islamic i think
is a big mistake well and
the other issue here is obama is trying
to avoid this phrase
islamic extremism and this is actually
the same kind of challenge that
president bush
confronted as well he also struggled
with how to define this sort of
terrorism at first he began with the
rhetoric of the crusades and he kind of
backed off of that because it
played into the whole clash of
civilizations and he eventually settled
on
referring to islamic radicalism but he
always said
as well that islam was the religion of
peace they both kind of
said that well if you say everybody
who's islamic is a terrorist you're
headed for trouble no one is saying that
okay well we agree then uh by the way
no one is saying that what we got from
uh that article
i think is he he kind of recommended
containing things
right i don't know that you can contain
at this point
you need to bring the world together to
decide what are we going to fight for
i want to see some sunni arab states
have a stake in this saudi arabia needs
to have a spirit
but this idea that we cannot even call
it islamic terrorism
seems orwellian to me it seems like
we're paying a very high price for this
which is we can't discuss it even
rationally he
can't we at least say that there are a
number of factors that are involved and
the
religion is certainly one of them
absolutely this idea he presented this
idea that well it's poverty
and education it is poverty and
education also but why are they
impoverished and uneducated
it's mostly because of the religion
that's mostly why
the u.n did a study in 2002 they found
out that only
300 books had been translated into
arabic
that year in madras's they only teach
one book i don't have to tell you
what do you think about pumping the
internet into there somehow
so that everybody had access to all of
these books
uh yeah that's another thing that
religion might be against
yeah and not to mention the sex part
yeah they're up about women they
can't work and
some of them can't go to a workplace
because they're dressed like you with oh
my god your arms are showing
well i will say part of isis's strategy
is actually employing social media in
the use of technology in the us
government their own good
for their own good to push their
propaganda and that's something that the
us government is realizing that they're
really far behind on
now they're talking about how do we
utilize this technology i don't know if
twitter accounts from the united states
are really going to be effective in this
fight but they are kind of using this
tool of the west to push their
agenda very sophisticated i mean you had
all of these bathursts
that were basically thrown out of uh
saddam's people saddam's people
were very sophisticated military guys
who formed the basis of
of isis he and qaddafi always said to
america you don't understand what i'm
dealing with
yes i'm a bad guy but you have no idea
how crazy some of the people in my
country are
i am keeping the to shoe level you
should be thanking me
well and the other issue at play is that
during the summit there were a lot of
leaders from these different states who
they come from countries where they are
committing gross human rights abuses as
well
so there's this kind of conflict like do
we ask these nations to really get
involved in this fight
while they're also treating their own
citizens poorly they don't point the
spotlight at us
yeah kind of but the iraq war i i think
when we look back
it might be the biggest blunder in
american history biggest
ever biggest because there would not be
an isis without it
absolutely it's just the biggest it is
the quagmire that
in is lifetime and i've lived through
vietnam as we have
and i think jeb bush at some point is
going to have to answer well
say are you on the same page as your
brother with this because
this is this is a disaster or is it
going to be certain he's able to smooth
over well he already has a good time
he kind of answered that already because
he gave a speech this week
and he said that isis fighters i think
the figure he had was 200 000. yeah he
was off by 180 thousand he's off by a
hundred people
and then he corrected later said and
they said yeah
on fox news they were like it's no big
deal really you're trying to be the
litter in the free world and you're off
by a factor of ten
yeah and you're this and you're the
smart bush yeah
um but you know what
okay so there's 20 000 isis fighters
here's what i keep saying every week
why can't the people in the region take
care of this without
us i i did a little research here an old
question
let me tell you let me give you the
numbers of the armed forces
of jordan 180 000 turkey
991 000 egypt 1.4 million iraq 800 000.
the kurds
have up to 250 000 the saudis 250 000
lebanon 280
syria 600 there's almost 5
million people without iran who might
want to kick some sunni ass
why can't they do why can't they put
some boots on the ground if they have 5
million against 20
000. well it's also an issue of how much
funding and sophistication those
military forces have and additionally
there are a lot of voices in the u.s
government a lot of politicians who are
worried about countries like iran
exerting a lot of influence in that
region because that might not be
productive or useful for the united
states to have them exerting all that
charming choice of words productive yeah
not productive i've always felt that
you have to have yeah if this is going
to be a sectarian
war and it has become one you're going
to need
countries that are basically sunni
countries like saudi arabia
have a stake in it to say let's let's
have
iran or any other shia nations come in
there and fight
yeah of course they want to fight
because they want to fight the sunnis
but we need
sunni boots on the ground so basically
say we don't
accept this kind of behavior are is it
going uh
like gaddafi uh they were
suppressing things letting keeping it
the at shoe level
are they expecting the u.s to be doing
the same thing well i mean
so as long as the us is in there they're
expecting us to bail them out
so a great moment for moderate muslims
who i hear so much about
why don't you go to the middle east and
fight isis isis is always attracting
other people from other countries to
come to the middle east where are the
moderates who want to go
fight isis if they're so bad if they
hate isis so much
you know during the spanish civil war
americans went to spain
americans had no immediate fight there
but to stand up for liberalism where's
that
crickets